wikis wieder am start mit einem neuen
video für euch und mit einer neuen drei
uhr nachts rechtsschutz davor wirklich
weil es wieder wird der verfluchten
puppe ist leute mal wieder die
verfluchte gruppe man kennt sie rebecca
wing einigen von euch wird dieser name
was sagen und die denken sich jetzt zu
recht ach du scheiße bitte nicht aber es
gibt schon noch einige zeit da draußen
die j keine ahnung haben von welcher
youtuber nicht gerade deswegen hier ein
kurzer anstieg rebecca ist ein youtube
mit fast 1,5 millionen abonnenten und
etwas spezielleren content und was soll
ich sagen es ist an der zeit dass ich
dazu mal meine meinung abgeben
vor allem dieses video alte oh mein gott
ja allein die titel gesehen hab ich
schon gedacht
diese scheiße ich so selbstgefällig hilf
mir müsste die box im keller gefunden
das muss so recht sein oder ich will
doch nicht so viel sagen leute ich will
ja nicht so viel sagen ich habe es
wirklich im blut dass das jetzt gefällt
dass ich habe so getäuscht denn das ist
so typisch sollten face heiße es laut
dir dass du eine packende story box das
was ich das wort wird es eine mystery
box wieso sollte man den mystery box
sind sagt keiner finden hast du deinen
keller irgendwelche youtuber eingesperrt
die daten video aufnehmen und deswegen
sich die mystery box bestellt haben wie
soll ich denn sonst die leute
ok also bereits bei der sachbearbeiter
geht's los ist aber ich weiß bei der
kellertür bei mir gefunden und ich weiß
nicht von wem das ist sorry leute sorry
wenn nicht unterbrechen
ich hoffe ich bin nicht der einzige dem
es so geht aber das schreit doch so nah
felix schreiner völlig und die bewertung
21.000 dax nur 1000 discs schlecht aber
ich weiß nicht was ich wiedergeben
scherz erlaubt oder soweit halloween ist
oder so keine ahnung ich habe das hier
gefunden und zwar habe ich diese ewige
boxee gefunden
was glaubst doch selbst nicht also was
ist denn daran eklat aus weil das ist
einfach das pappkiste zoll oder wie
gesagt die müssen wir sagen euch jetzt
die reaktion sehr hart vorkommt ich weiß
einfach dass die scheiße gefaked ist
deswegen bin ich jetzt schon etwas
gereizt in meinen reaktionen und ich
muss sagen dass es keine ewig ist uwe
becker das ist ein pappkarton dong gok
ja da gut da sehen wir dass jenny meiner
lieben youtube kollegin rebecca wien an
der arbeit ich will gar nicht anfassen
und in dem moment sie hat den satz ich
will die kiste nicht anfassen noch nicht
fertig gesprochen schon top studie sieht
einfach schlecht gepflegt aus beim
besten willen leute ich kann es nicht
glauben dass leute eine youtube das
abnehmen und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
leute das war's mit deutschland wir
können uns als land komplett vernichten
und alle in urlaub fahren für immer wenn
wir 20.000 menschen in diesem land haben
die so eine rotze glauben ich meine das
ist das echte leben leute so man findet
keine müsste wie boxen im keller genauso
wenig wie man in den garten geht und
dann zufällig in eine
und trifft so spaziert aber nicht ich
kann dir mal hochleben
da sehen wir wieder recording ganz
konsequent dabei sie hat eine
entscheidung getroffen und die zieht die
eiskalt und konsequent durch sie hat
sich gesagt ich werde diese kiste nicht
anfassen und fasst die kiste innerhalb
der nächsten 30 sekunden natürlich
zweimal an ich werde jetzt einfach nicht
trauen
an der stelle und das muss sich in
dieser klarheit noch mal sagen leute
bitte eine schweigeminute für bekkering
die sich getraut hat die kiste die sie
selbst in ihren keller gelegt hat wie
damit nach oben zu nehmen und zu öffnen
[Musik]
aber komme das ist nicht dein ernst ganz
ehrlich wisst ihr was sie gemacht hat
das sieht für mich danach aus als wäre
sie einmal in den keller gegangen hätte
so die ihre kiste mit halloween artikeln
plastik spinnen spinnen letzten hüten
war aber einmal genommen in die kiste
gepackt und weißt du was die ganze rotte
hier ist mir scheißegal ich tue einfach
mal so als wäre das eine mystery box
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend
was sollen wir dazu noch sagen leute
sagen wir so es ist doch lächerlich es
ist so lächerlich okay im restlichen
video packt sie einfach nur keine ahnung
die kiste aus
absolut okay okay das habe ich mich auch
gern gesehen sie baut scheinbar ihre
fake videos auch aufeinander auf also
sehr cool sie dieses video mit dem mit
der box erkunden gefällt und war aber
schlau genug in die boxen usb stick
reisen tun damit sie dann noch ein video
über den usb stick machen kann und das
schauen was jetzt mal das video ist
natürlich öffne wirklich niemals usb
stick von fremden aus keller und ich
habe es jetzt schon gesehen das so so
viele meinten ich solle unbedingt gucken
was auch die so richtig lustig drauf ist
nicht korrekt so war sogar ins league zu
sagen dass er das grün geben wirklich
keinen grund in epe zu nehmen nix gutes
draus er ich habe wirklich angst davor
man die sachen die allein schon eine box
sah man schon creepy und bestellt so war
es vor die kellertür von einem falsch
die eigentliche frage ist und die frage
müsste uns wirklich alle machte zunge
zergehen lassen leute wer stellt sich so
eine kiste selbst in den keller tut dann
so als hätte sie gefunden und welche
gruppe an zuschauern in deutschland
österreich und der schweiz teilt es
nicht dass die kacke fake ist bis zum
gehtnichtmehr
irgendwie leuchtet der computer ist ein
schöner
er wird auf jeden fall erkannt 66
[Applaus]
ich kann es wirklich nicht leute ich
kann das nicht ich kann mir nicht so was
anschauen oder aber dass meine
gehirnzellen schrumpfen und verdampfen
nein das ist ein luftballon
was gibt es da zu sein
oh mein gott
[Musik]
und was passiert jetzt eigentlich wissen
beim minute vier von 15 was macht die
jetzt noch spielt das noch mal
sie sagt aber nein ich kann es ihm einen
keller gehen
ein kuscheltier dieses kuscheltier habe
ich nicht selbst in meinen keller gelegt
bitte kriegt weiterhin auf meinem videos
sie sind nicht gefragt und dann aber zu
erweitern auch wahrscheinlich so aus
jetzt zu den teddy bear eingestellt ok
also ich weiss nicht also für mich ist
das kein problem ich mir so vorstelle
wie so becker wien denkt und das ist so
der schreckliche teddybär aus dem keller
[Musik]
gestern ich irgendwie verflucht oder so
wünscht man sich den möglichen seinem
keller stellen neben diesen wunderbaren
klassikern haben wir natürlich auch das
video rhede 3 uhr nachts mit verfluchter
puppe auch das schauen wir es eben
nochmals mal wieder die verfluchte
gruppe man kennt sich ganz kurz wo
bekommt man verfluchte puppen in
verfluchten laden direkt neben dem red
bull stall
okay aber ganz ehrlich ich kann mir das
gesagt noch nicht haben wollen wie es
gibt mal zu den park wo sie mit der pop
art basel jetzt bewegt
jetzt hat sie auch so eine fake
abgezogen wie heißt die austria die
austria die um natürlich wir alle kennen
sie schätzen sie und benutzen sie
täglich die gute kost radiohead wenn man
auf dem weg zur schule oder auf dem klo
ist mal wieder mit geistern
kommunizieren muss ist es wirklich es
hart für mich heute mit anzuschauen
der stadt präsent nein nicht mehr normal
das ist wirklich nicht mehr da war heute
ist die puppe verflucht den faqs auf die
puppe flugzeug ist die puppe selbst das
geht gar nicht du kannst keine
verfluchte puppe fragen ob sie verflucht
ist das ist unhöflich glaub mir ich bin
fluchte puppe ist die gruppe verflucht
wird gefragt und die antwort ist an der
stelle selbstverständlicher weise welt
die verfüllung puppe antwortet auf die
frage ob sie verflucht ist mit welt an
der stelle bin ich für diesen tag diese
woche diesen monat dieses jahr und
dieses leben einmal sagte ich komplett
raus ich kann dazu nur sagen heute stop
trading